die 1000 wichtigsten politiker
deutschlands folge 1001 christian
schmidt christian schmidt unser minister
für steckrüben und kuhscheiße
wahrscheinlich der beste den deutschland
in dieser woche hatte oberflächliche
menschen sagen der typ ist ja total
harmlos der sieht aus wie eine scheibe
bierschinken der mann eine brille
aufgesetzt hat aber das täuscht
was hat der schmied für riesen einer
weisung aus dem kanzleramt
leck mich doch ich habe aber bock auf
glyphosat ich fühle mich verpflichtet in
der bundesregierung die dinge zu
entscheiden
zur entscheidung anstehen und so ist das
mit so ist er der schmidt 1 christian
schmidt macht was er will
genau wie ein lothar matthäus dieser
mann muss minister bleiben was der in
den letzten jahren alles an geschoben
und dann nicht fertig gelegt hat blüten
schreddern zum beispiel findet schmid
furchtbar
trotzdem bleibt erlaubt deutschlands
äcker sind so mit gülle zu geschissen
dass sich schon die ersten schweine über
den gestank beschweren
trotzdem kein gesetz gegen
massentierhaltung dafür weiß 1 christian
aber was gegen aggressive russen hilft
apple a day keeps putin away
absolut jeden tag einen apfel und ein
6er träger glyphosat und du wirst nie
wieder krank den schmidt kannst du
nachts um drei decken wer weiß ob nicht
eine antwort
chrissi was war nochmal titel der trans
atlantic treaty
guter mann übrigens seit mehreren wochen
auch noch kommissarisch verkehrsminister
und ich hatte mich schon gewundert warum
ich jetzt noch mehr im stau stehe als
sonst ehrlich ich bin fan und habe
deswegen in diesem neuen cocktail nach
christian schmidt genannt enthält zu
gleichen teilen glyphosat gülle und
lebende küken auch ich christian du bist
der geilste die 1000 wichtigsten
politiker deutschlands
von hubert mooser